welcome to this video player shamatha
nastradamus from lebanon yes I it far d
I'd fadi no I don't know this guy I've
never played them before at least with
this the count okay we got a scotch
scotch game this some line recently has
gained some popularity and it's a very
solid choice for white yeah age six is
the main move according to two theory
but it is very dull this exchange on at
six I try to be a bit more vicious with
Bishop e7 but it's it's not easy at all
to blame it's also always this Queenie
three moves yeah I tend to screw up the
move orders that's okay how came let's
see maybe this wasn't some precise
actually yeah I should play h6 first one
point is if he goes let's say nitey one
for example just a move I play h6 he
will take age six and Queen g3 check
picks up the rook on ba to the ruckus a
bit loose IAM because green g3 i have
looked before intending look G also this
sir is probably all right yeah is
thinking understandably because of opa
this may be a bit bit shaky mmm yeah it
is it's relatively normal way to play
but it's not so clear that it is really
working in this precise position
and now and that's also i know h6e can
really take 93 25 might be M I'm a plan
Bishop here and then back well I don't
know h6 I think he can really take
complete [ __ ] up g4 on this check but
it looks terrible yeah maybe just just
develop here but he can play of course
493 to f5 Oh what well that's a shocking
new for them is this working I don't
really understand it okay
okay you're sick thanks that this Bishop
f6 and takes on h7 but turkey this can
never be really great would be a really
surprising maybe yeah I don't know it
takes okay I cannot spend all day here
but this is certainly a bit of a fishy
sacrifice I cannot believe that it's
really great played that very quickly
the most term committal moves are often
played absolutely instantaneously which
yeah I know now is thinking what else
did you expect that Queen d6 here I mean
there there are many other ways to not
lose instantly but okay anyway if he
takes the question is I was intending
rook takes but Queen takes h7 yeah but
when I can they can in play king of a
devil want the check is completely
pointless I have everything covered yeah
but it's maybe a draw is this may be
Bishop takes a better way to play for
wind get the King to e7 maybe yeah maybe
let's do there to get the King 37 Jim I
should be quite save only 7 i'm on a
dark square and he does not have a dark
squared bishop and the night and the
rook are not in the attack at least not
yet he's basically taking with Queen and
Bishop only check
yeah Bishop g6 is really pointless I
mean I want to go here anyway and I'm 30
near okay Jade so this is probably the
least possible but look h8 now that I
think of it even less encounter pleiades
on h2 yeah okay i will able to do that
anyway checked in this game the smooth
now let's let's check what to do the
Queen we are the Queen does not have any
great squares really i can i can win win
some tempe here
queen bee 5am not rename 93 f 5 is quite
quite a possibility
and I wondered maybe this one just to
take the slide over the PS only three or
whatever yeah and now just take it just
take it okay Queen f4 okay that's 87
hanging actually and Queen g5 threatened
okay
yeah that's not not one not not to
satisfactory I said this to great okay
yeah well this isn't the mole check horn
horn but still it wasn't necessary to
give it up so it's just an exchange and
he's got two pawns now chai morning
check check check okay this is a big
gamble really funny but I don't want to
draw I mean let's let's fight it's maybe
g5g for
cheer for ya if i take let's check in
that's quite quite a problem okay maybe
I'm still here and then if I be for
something like that check okay okay stop
the a pawn just a moment and I'll try to
get the King to d4 and then push my
pawns check yeah this is silly check no
yeah okay oh how unnecessary is that now
I've got all our poles a week now great
great yeah this was a Catholic problem
check Jam stupid very stupid play by me
should never lose this position of
course never check
I'm not sure what he's doing here so
check so it's a winner in every which
way but check check check check check
black for fits on time what happens here
my fall-free long time what happened hey
summer I did it just jump to the first
first move okay yeah well how
unnecessary with that I mean he just the
sacrifice is completely unsound of
course check like this is much better
here but I I didn't play it play it play
it really well I mean okay this is a
concession of course but I wanted to
have the safe King computer just wants
to play Queenie fight with the win yeah
keeping it on but it always difficult to
do it let's check check check check
check yeah okay I wanted to try to win
here check turn I mean I mean of course
black know under normal circumstances
can never lose the position what I did
though was just stupid this is just
blundering it away in one move I mean I
also cannot win but I shouldn't lose
really because white only has the a pond
and that's that that shouldn't really
win the game now I have lower gutom
active plan here though
well I can basically black can just stay
put and nothing happens but of course if
for was just just suicidal something
like that and then just just do nothing
white white also has no way forward
really because if you try to use the H
point I mean I'm basically threatening
to a threatened threatened is a bit much
but I'm intend to maybe use the King to
keep the porn so you cannot easily play
play here for example and we're well
anyway the H pawn is not promoting
promoting any way they are so it seems
that I shouldn't really I shouldn't take
on III but this is always a bit tricky
to do having okay rookie six yeah hard
to believe okay but anyway check then
the real point is that okay besides the
fact that there were other moves I
shouldn't take here and just play 25m
but I am I didn't feel I wanted to have
wanted to get rid of the night it's
always this tricky piece with the Fox
yeah you know this is what the computer
wants to do King twin f3 take him and
and this this year yeah this is of
course much better in terms of porn
structure and of course giving away that
I lost the apron which was really a
shame and this also wasn't necessary at
all really yeah but now it's hard to
keep him that's the real problem it's a
double check with the after Queen takes
with Queen here and queen here and this
is the real problem Jim check Jim that
is just very
let me play them like alright thanks for
watching